what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Skippy the Virgin I
have actually never seen Skippy the
Virgin like a full clip of his before so
I'm excited don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
like the video on your way and let's get
started
low testosterone
I want a girl to be like wait you're
saying how are you still single
oh no
hey Mom the ideal girl isn't thinking
that her ideal guy still lives at home
in Mom's basement right no she ain't oh
it's coming
but I do would you like to know how
badly I want to have sex with a girl
it's all I've been able to think about
all last night I just like sit there
with girls sometimes on dates like
you're the cutest you're the sweetest
you're the best let's cuddle you want a
coat
okay this is an unpopular opinion I
think there's a need for hookers for
this exact reason because who's gonna do
that I don't know a single girl in her
right mind who's gonna who's gonna do
that
I I'm not saying anyone I love should be
a hooker but like someone's got to do it
yeah you're not like it's the world's
oldest profession I can't tell you you
know if you want to go on a date with me
well would a t-shirt change your mind
I made out with Skippy for three minutes
and all I got was this lousy t-shirt
make the world a better place put a kiss
on Skippy's face you may be thirsty for
some Skippy got Skippy okay but dude get
in shape it's like you want these girls
so bad that you're making t-shirts
before you're gonna eat less and go to
the gym oh my God huh huh I'm sorry I
don't feel bad look at I don't feel bad
for single women okay and I have a lot
of empathy for single men that have good
job I've heard stories of guys that have
good jobs they're in the gym and like
the stories they tell me about the way
women treat them when they have a lot of
things going for them like honestly like
I have a lot of empathy for that but
this
this you're living in your mom's
basement you're overweight and you're
wondering why you can't get laid what on
Earth and you're making t-shirts before
you get it get a good job and I don't
know go to the freaking gym get on the
treadmill
oh tonight he's going out to meet girls
with his wing mom his wing Mom do you
know where you should be going to the
gym
hey Nancy we're going by I like that one
you are so weird what are you doing no
no don't circle around me because that's
gonna you know don't no just walk up and
be like son remember the girl from like
two songs ago she was cute maybe you
should ask her again okay my role is
Wing mom and so I'll kind of keep an eye
on the ladies
when I mean does he have a dad no some
of these Like Son husbands
y'all moms are part of the problem the
girl that I fall in love with I want her
and my mom to be really good friends
[Music]
tonight could be the beginnings of my
start I would tell you to go after some
chicks and single moms because that's
what you qualify for single moms with
two or three baby daddies that's what
you qualify for I'm sorry sir your mom's
basement
Eternal Bliss at 34 34.
[Music]
thank you
do I meet my mom
[Music]
I'm really sweaty and there's an outlet
in the bathroom so I'm gonna go dry off
somebody had this tree okay okay you you
your first thing that you want to tell a
girl she you know how self-centered
women are we're not paying attention to
you I know do you think she's gonna
notice if you don't wear cologne we are
self-centered women oh my God we think
about ourselves 90 of the time we're not
thinking about you all you got to do is
get a girl to just start talking yeah
and you're telling me that your next
move was to introduce her to your mom
and dip because you're too sweaty uh
maybe if you went to the gym like I
suggested
guys this is Skippy oh no hey guys
I've got so much more personality than
any other guy in here like it's a race
for number two because the like funniest
the most creative guy just walked into
the room
hi Stephanie I'm Skippy this is our
party sort of his but mine Skippy likes
to make t-shirts
yeah yeah yeah yeah because I am in fact
fun and single and ready to mingle if I
have other shirts y'all invited two
hottest chicks to this event you should
have invited some uglier broads that he
might have more success like these these
girls okay guys in the room smash or
pass see I know the lightning stock
right but smash or pass from what you
can see yeah yes we're all three easy
right two and that's generous I think
his face isn't bad and if it wasn't for
like the personality and the the job and
the you going out to your mom
um to the bars he could be you know like
a five or six I don't think it's like I
feel like he has a face that's not like
ugly do you know what I'm saying like
his face is like like it's ugly because
he's fat like if he wasn't fat he'd
probably just be I think most people
would be normal looking if they weren't
fat I think there's very few people that
like their face is so bad that it's like
you know what I mean there's some I just
yeah maybe he'd be a four I don't know
but my point is I I don't we need to get
some uglier broads at these parties you
don't qualify for these women no are you
yes how single are you though
I see Skippy do certain things I'm just
like oh man somebody's got to talk to
this guy and I I just told him I said
Skippy you gotta you gotta kind of come
off a little bit less excited if you do
want to kiss me my answer is yes and
then you can have this awesome shirt
what if I can see on the cheek no no no
no no it says I made out with Skippy for
three minutes it doesn't say I kissed
Skippy on the cheek Skippy doesn't
really listen so I'm trying to help him
to see that you know play a little bit
more cool or a little bit more casual
when you're when you're meeting girls I
I need a girlfriend I'm in a rut in my
life where I need companionship you
don't need a girlfriend I swear to God
you don't need a girlfriend you need a
gym membership and a better job I don't
know if he has a job but if you don't
have a job you need a better one what
Jimmy has in muscles I have in
personalities
I hate to brag but that's kind of the
case so I'm 34 years old I'm a virgin
and I'm awesome I'm really awesome and
I'm a good person and if you got to know
me you would think so too I feel like we
need to get to know each other a little
better I would love it if we got to know
each other better do you feel that there
was chemistry here right
[Music]
number yeah yeah yeah yeah oh girl stop
leading him ah stop doing this to him
you know damn well you ain't interested
I think he's great he's a great kid good
is that does that mean I want to [ __ ]
you do you agree he's a great kid he's
so sweet how's that when girls say that
does that usually result in the men
getting laid guys no oh
for me right for me
oh he got a date with her in his pair
I bet she's there for the TV I I think
that's why she said yes
[Music]
I'm gonna get that for you
thank you
oh I should totally give you a tour okay
perfect welcome to my room here's my
poster of the Osmonds and over here is
my belly button link collection
and she he couldn't take her to like a
restaurant or even coffee would be
better than this
sort of God coffee would be better
how many guys that you got on dates with
in the last year still live at home
you have your future kids names picked
out
uh no I've had my future kids names
picked out since I was 14.
I don't want to go on a first date with
a girl and have a think that I'm
interviewing her to be my wife but it's
always in the back of my head
so now what
I've got
um I've got a surprise don't go anywhere
if you want to kind of clean this up or
something like that but I'll be right
back down okay oh I can do that
I don't feel bad for you Skippy oh my
God
so let me get this straight
you get a chance a small barely no
chance but a chance like all right all
right guys guys this girl's cute right
smell you you smash right right would
you give her like six seven six okay
okay you taking her on a date are you
taking her to your parents basement
taking her to a steakhouse yeah yeah
he's taking it where are you taking her
blessing
he says not there not there so it's like
do I feel bad that this is gonna go
south and now do you think it's
appropriate to talk about your future
kids names on a first date no do you
think it's appropriate to talk about
to have the girl clean up the pizza box
you're okay with that yeah I just feel
like if you're in her parents basement
oh my God
surprise can you come in oh no what is
the surprise share your talents with us
[Music]
oh that's kind of cute
grams can we slow that question sure
yeah can I be big spoon and you be
little spin I like a girl that's shorter
than me I want to be able to put my arm
around her and just kind of like sway at
a concert like to me that's great and to
me that's cute whenever I see people
doing that I'm like oh I want to be them
oh no
oh no
[Music]
I aspire to be a great big spoon
so Pearl what would you do if you were
in this situation right now
first of all I wouldn't have said yes to
be
assume you said yes now you're in the
situation yeah with Skippy you're being
spooned by Skippy right now what do you
do I it's only halfway through the song
I would probably like just be really
awkward yeah yeah that's like I just
would be like ah let's let's just sit
and enjoy it let's just sit down and
enjoy these I honestly kind of I kind of
[ __ ] with the guitar like that's that's
kind of cute yeah I like I like
countries you're saying you would like
this if a guy did this on a first date
you would you would like okay not not
the basement thing but I like I like
country music so if you took me to go
see country music I would like that
would be a date I would like because I I
like but that would require him paying
for tickets Skippy doesn't have a job
well you could just go to a bar that
like there's free music in Nashville
you're from Nashville that's true that's
true you're just like the king of free
music that's true so if that was like a
bar setting I would like that but in
your parents basement yeah
awesome
oh no
so if you want to start heading upstairs
there's like one last little surprise at
the end of the night okay
I'll miss you
before I give you this and before I walk
you to the door I really do think that I
did pretty good on this date if maybe if
I ask nicely
can I please
just give you a kiss
and sometimes
you know what that's funny when I went
to the pickup artist like boot camp it's
sad to
can I kiss you and I hated that I was
like I mean if it was chatter Tyrone you
know every girl's saying yeah but like
for the average guy I'm like I don't
know maybe that works I mean they teach
it so I'm like it surely works on
someone but that I don't like that you
just are horny and you just like what
you need my permission wanna kiss and
you want like some rough stuff but not
Bishop not talk to Bishop bruh but you
want kind of like
it doesn't have to be giant that can can
I guarantee does that work can I just
can I just give you a kiss please I just
I don't kiss on the first date
for you for you I swear to God is this
Brad Pitt that girl wanting to kiss a
girl shouldn't be a shock to a cute girl
did right
[Music]
oh okay
thank you that's all for tonight's kitty
yeah there is not gonna be a second date
so this is um an episode of why I don't
feel bad you're not getting laid I feel
bad for guys that actually have put in
the work but for this and you need to
shoot lower Skippy I'm sorry that is too
hot for you you need to go to like a
three you're a two I'll I'll give you a
three no I'm serious there's some that
need love a lot of them have stitched my
tick tocks mm-hmm
anyways like the video on your way out
I'm so tired of blessing and Kobe doing
this to me I'm so tired of this [ __ ]
um they both got fired today they both
are unemployed
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible